we welcome you back to CBS Mornings in
our old studio for most of this
country's history homosexuals were not
allowed to serve in the military service
members found to be gay were discharged
often less than honorably that was a
black mark that affected their future
benefits and their job opportunities too
still there are an estimated 1 million
lgbtq veterans in this country and we
don't know how many were forced out of
the military before and after that don't
tell that don't ask don't tell policy
CBS News Chief investigative
correspondent that's Jim Axelrod spoke
with veterans who've spent years trying
to regain their honor and claim those
benefits Jim good morning to you well
good morning don't ask don't tell was
born of a compromise when Bill Clinton's
promise to normalize gays and lesbians
serving openly in the military ran
headlong into pushback at the Pentagon
then Barack Obama said we can do better
well that was more than a dozen years
ago and thousands of gay veterans still
haven't had the Discrimination they
suffered addressed
the standing ovation in 2010 celebrated
Noble ideals no longer will tens of
thousands of Americans in uniform be
asked to live a lie as President Obama
repealed the policy that it kept gay and
lesbian service members closeted and
fearful for nearly 18 years if you put
your hand on your hip if you sit with
your legs like it was always like The
Witch Hunt was always around no matter
what during those times in the military
which explains why vets like Donnie Ray
Allen a former Marine and Amy long who
served in the Navy were skeptical
anything would change both had been
kicked out of the military for don't ask
don't tell violations with less than
honorable discharges did it change your
sense of self
yes I'm less than
less than yeah I'm less than honorable
for Amy and Donnie Ray and many other
lgbtq vets that meant losing access to
the full spectrum of benefits veterans
get when honorably discharged from VA
loans to tuition assistance to health
care and many federal jobs it's a dark
very dark place place
was any thought given to how we're going
to deal with the people
who have suffered to be frank the focus
was
on the future Leon Panetta was the
Secretary of Defense who oversaw the
repeals almost a dozen years ago there
wasn't a lot of thought about you know
the people who'd been discharged who'd
gone through hell on this issue about
what do we do about them and in some
ways I regret that the best estimates
are that 14
000 service members were discharged
under don't ask don't tell homophobia
had chased out many more well before but
the most recent data shows just a little
over 1200 have had this Injustice
addressed which means the overwhelming
number of people who were
less than honorably discharged for their
sexuality
still have not had their discharges
upgraded it's like everything else when
it comes to civil rights
in order to be able to move forward and
embrace the future
uh you can't just push the past aside
tell that to Andrew Espinosa who's not
just less than in the eyes of the
military he doesn't exist at all all
right so this one I was in training
still he was a proud Air Force Aviator
in the late 80s and early 90s flying 21
combat missions as a navigator
but in May of 1993 a few months before
don't ask don't tell was implemented but
in the middle of a debate raging about
whether gay people could serve I don't
have anything against gays but I don't
think it's there's a place in the
military Andrew Espinosa's life changed
forever and they said well there's an
accusation that there was someone in
your room and uh that you put your hand
on his knee and kissed him on the cheek
just the accusation itself set these
Wheels in Motion
that
never stopped the allegation of a kiss
on the cheek turned into an indictment
for indecent assault and threats from
the Air Force or we're bringing you to
court marshall and it's not going to be
anything to do with sexuality
that you are going to be charged with
indecent assault
which is a federal felony despite the
Air Force admitting homosexuality was a
factor in his case in a letter to
espinoza's Mother he was court-martialed
and dishonorably discharged Captain
Espinosa had no health care and no
benefits he couldn't even get hired as a
census taker is it a stretch in the
early 90s to say that what the Air Force
was doing
wasn't about indecent assault it was
about criminalizing this guy's sexuality
yeah I'm sure somebody said well let's
use that as the excuse veterans like Amy
and Donnie Ray have gone through
official channels to get the discharge
upgrades they need to access the
benefits they've earned but it's been a
long and often soul-crushing Road when
did you first attempt to get your
discharge upgraded
shoot back in like 2013 or so and
nothing yeah and it just stalled I mean
there was just there didn't feel like
there was any hope for anything and
while just two weeks ago Donnie Ray
finally got his upgrade even saying it
like I can't stop smiling because I'm
just like wow like it actually happened
Andrew Espinosa has given up I'm just
like okay we're done we're done I'm not
gonna go beg and for Leon Panetta that's
a grievous wrong that urgently needs to
be made right in order
to be true to what we tried to do by
getting rid of don't ask don't tell it's
not just about the future it's also
about making sure that we correct the
past
in a statement of CBS News the Pentagon
said it has conducted several Outreach
campaigns for veterans who think they
were wrongly discharged but acknowledged
it has quote more work to do the
Department of Defense also said it has
tried hard to mitigate delays and is
still striving to finalize cases within
10 months I think it's good to hear Leon
Panetta say he has some regrets about
how it was handled and to say you can't
push the past aside that applies to many
many things in life but we saw what
happened to Donnie Ray what about the
other two veterans all right so we asked
about Amy long the neighbors said can't
talk about it privacy concerns I want to
make a few points about Andrew Espinoza
the Air Force says that it continues to
stand by its decision to deny the
discharge upgrade request but that he
can reapply if new evidence is
discovered but I want to be crystal
clear about one thing Andrew has always
maintained his innocence says the
incident in question never happens never
happens I'm hoping that this story will
make a difference for both of them for
both of them 2023 to hear Leon Panetta
that's encouraging that kind of Candor
but that's just a step this justice has
been elusive for a long time a long time
too long thank you